Today, I'm going
to talk about how
to make Shiny apps faster
with caching using features
from the new version
of Shiny version 1.6.
Here's an app that shows
average weather patterns
over the course of a
year, so let's take a look
at the weather where
I live in Minneapolis.
We'll load the data.
And the weather here
is pretty typical for
the continental United States.
It's hot in the summer,
cold in the winter,
and it rains more in the
summer, and less in the winter.
I have relatives that live in
the Bay Area in California.
And sometimes, I compare
my weather to theirs,
and I feel a little sad.
But then I compare
real estate prices,
and I feel a lot better.
So here's the weather for
Redwood City, California.
In the summer, it's warm.
In the winter, it's
cooler, but it doesn't ever
get really cold.
And in the winter,
it rains a lot.
And in the summer, it
rains almost not at all.
Now with this app,
there's a button
that you can use to switch
between the previous city
and the current one.
So let's switch to Minneapolis
by clicking on there, and back
to Redwood City by
clicking on it again.
But you notice
that every time we
do that, it has to rego
out and refetch the data.
And then redraw the plots,
and that takes time.
And so this experience of
switching back and forth
isn't really a great one.
Now how can we make it better?
Well, the answer
is with caching.
Here's some simplified
code from the app.
We have the weather data,
which is a reactive expression.
And that calls a function
called fetchData,
and you give that the city that
you want to fetch the data for.
That goes out to the internet.
It grabs the data,
and then it returns.
This takes a while.
This is the slowest
part of the application.
In Shiny 1.6, we've added a
function called bindCache.
The way it works is you pass
your reactive expression
to the bindCache
function, and then you
tell it what to use
as the cache key.
In this case, it's
input dollar city.
So the first time you
have a particular value
of input dollar city, it will
run the reactive expression,
and store the
value in the cache.
And then if you ever have
that same value again,
instead of having to recompute
the reactive expression,
it can just fetch the old
value out of the cache.
And in this case, that
means we don't know
we don't have to go to the
internet to fetch the data.
The other part of our app
that takes significant time
is the plot rendering
with renderPlot.
And as it turns out, you can
use bindCache with a renderPlot
as well.
So that the plots for a
particular city instead
of having to be
recomputed every time,
they can be simply
fetched from the cache.
And this can really
speed things up.
OK, let's look at app again,
but this time with caching.
So all we did was add bindCache
to the reactive expression
and to the renderPlots,
and that's it.
Now when we look
at these cities,
and switch back and
forth between them,
it's pretty much instantaneous.
Because instead of
having to fetch the data
and recompute the
plots, it just grabs
the plots and the data
right out of the cache,
which is very, very fast.
So we've seen bindCache use with
reactive and with renderPlot.
And I should mention
that before Shiny 1.6,
it was possible to use
caching with plots by using
the renderCachedPlot function.
But that's now equivalent
to using a renderPlot
and bindCache.
But it doesn't stop
there, you can also
use bindCache with other render
functions like renderText.
And it will even work
with render functions that
are not in Shiny itself
like renderPlotly
from the plotly package.
All you have to do is add
bindCache to the end of it.
If you've written one of
these render functions,
in most cases, it will
just work with bindCache.
But if not, typically the
changes that you need to make
are quite small just
a few lines of code.
There are a few details you
might be wondering about.
So first is the
size of the cache.
The default size is 200
megabytes in memory.
Now that size can be changed.
And instead of using
it memory, the cache
can also be stored on disk.
Next, the scope.
The cache is shared across all
user sessions of an application
by default. And that means
that if one person fetches
a particular data set or
views a particular plot,
then other users can
benefit from that.
But if that's a problem for
your particular use case,
then the cache can be scoped
to just one session instead.
Next, the lifetime.
A memory cache is discarded when
the app exits or it restarts.
But a disk based cache can
persist across app restarts,
and can even be shared across
multiple simultaneous R
processes serving
up the same app
as you might do with
Connect or Shiny Server Pro.
Thanks for listening,
and I hope that you
find bindCache useful for
speeding up and scaling up
your Shiny applications.